the Motion Picture Academy faces
backlash this morning over major changes
meant to boost TV ratings on Hollywood's
biggest night the Academy said yesterday
it will limit the telecast of the Oscars
ceremony to three hours and it will be
held earlier in the year to shorten the
awards season but the creation of a new
popular film category is stirring
outrage and forcing a difficult
conversation about race in Hollywood
since the show started 47 minutes ago
Black Panther made another 48 million
dollars comedian Jimmy Kimmel may have
foreshadowed an Oscar controversy at
last year's ceremony involving ratings
and a billion-dollar blockbuster Black
Panther has been so successful at the
box office they're already saying it's
the favorite to not get nominated for
anything next year now there's uproar
that the Academy is trying to recognize
movies like Black Panther without the
prestige the Academy announced a new
award Wednesday for outstanding
achievement in popular film critics say
the Academy is creating a separate but
equal category for overlooked but
popular minority led films like Black
Panther and Wonder Woman and offering
them consolation prizes to bring in more
viewers and improve ratings the Academy
is trying to get around the idea that
its own membership is not going to
nominate a Black Panther Elena rising is
a cultural reporter at the New York
Times if you're a black panther and you
get nominated for most popular film but
you don't get nominated for a Best
Picture well what does that make you is
that a second class kind of win last
year's show hit an all-time ratings low
variety reports that days later brass
from ABC which owns rights to the
telecast until 2028 met with the Academy
in a come-to-jesus meeting the
executives walk through the lousy
ratings identifying moments during the
show that prompted viewers to stop
watching then suggested fixes including
adding the new popular film category
grace issues have overshadowed the
Oscars for years
Oscar goes to in 2015 and 2016 all
nominees in the major acting categories
were white a controversy branded with
the hashtag oscarssowhite tonight we
honor Hollywood's best and widest sorry
brightest People's Choice Award so the
Academy is still working out details
like what qualifies as popular and this
isn't the first time the Academy has
responded to criticism after the dark
knight was snubbed for Best Picture ten
years ago the Academy doubled the number
of nominees in that category from five
to ten to make room for more films I'd
feel some kind of way if Black Panther
got nominated for popular movie and not
Best Picture because it should win on
the merits of being a really good film
any of those movies I'm writing a really
good film just nominate the film's for
the technical categories and not like it
enough even though they're trying not to
make it so not sure about the best order
that's good